pas la secrétaire d'état à l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes
la fiche en effet être coiffé devrait
réagir parce que vendredi elle sera aux
côtés de cyril hanouna l'animateur de
ces huit une émission spéciale dans le
cadre du grand débat national
le tandem n'est pas forcément un gage
des changes police et de réflexion
approfondie mais marlène schiappa elle
elle défend sa participation on les
écoute
avant de débattre de ce débat alors
d'abord ce qui est important de préciser
c'est que c'est cyril hanouna qui va
animer et faire l'animation du show et
des chroniqueurs parce que c'est lui
l'animateur de l'émission
moi je serai là pour animer la partie
des bas donc je vais venir avec mes
paperboard mes feutres weleda et puis
nous allons animer un débat comme si
nous animions un atelier du grand débat
national
et puis pourquoi cyril hahn non parce
que je vous rappelle que cyril hanouna
salon des premiers à avoir reçu des
gilets jaunes à avoir perçu l'ampleur de
ce phénomène dès le mois de novembre
alors même que tout le monde moi y
compris ils pensaient que c'était
quelque chose qui allait rapidement
s'essouffler
valérie toranian après tout pourquoi pas
franchement moi je trouve que c'est un
un débat sur un an débat quoi ou un non
débat sur un débat c'est à dire que bon
oui
cyril hanouna sais pas ce que je préfère
dans le paysage audiovisuel
mais c'est vrai qu'il touche un certain
nombre de gens et marines ya passé son
style elle a pas peur elle y va elle
fonce elle a déjà fait des plateaux elle
a déjà elle a pas peur enfin saisi gilet
jaune elle y va voilà on peut l'aimer
palais mais en tout cas moi je les
reconnais cette qualité là elle est en
mission elle les ja pour défendre son
gouvernement
bon franchement alors toute la question
de savoir oui mais elle serait
interviewé ce serait une chose mais
comme elle anime le débat n'est pas à sa
place je crois que la frontière est
quand même assez fragiles enfants à
cesser les genres moi j'ai l'impression
que le mélange des genres en soit c'est
pas sûr que non
ma ministre et ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur elle est très
réservé c'est rare d'ailleurs que c'est
là vraiment il ya un petit couac
gouvernemental est la trouve ça n est
pas du tout d'accord avec cette démarche
visiblement frédéric bedin louis et moi
j'ai un petit problème quand même avec
c'est sûr sur autre chose
ce qui me gêne c'est que marlène
schiappa qui est extrêmement brillante
et en effet dynamique là dans une
émission vous avez quand même très
controversée en dehors même de qui a été
très controversée qui a eu un rappel à
l'ordre sur des questions d'homophobie
qui va une très surprenant donc à la
germination sélective et des accords
très sélective c'est ça qui sur ce sujet
comme aussi sur le féminisme où elle a
un peu tendance à quand même à me voir
qu'une partie du spectre et la halle et
dans une émission où quand même on peut
pas dire que vu ses prises de position
générale elle devrait sentir
particulièrement à l'aise il est beau
l'argument ça touche des jeunes c'est un
public qui aime on a envie aussi de
sensibiliser aux grands débats et après
tout moi aussi alors pour une fois j'ai
envie de défendre plus tôt ah oui ça va
sur ses problèmes avec la critique du
féminisme sont général ou de ses excès
précisément mais mais là je pense qu'on
peut pas à la fois dire aux gens aux
hommes politiques à vous n'avez pas été
assez proche des gens vous leur ai pas
parlé vous n'avez pas essayé d'aller au
contact c'est ce qu'a fait emmanuel
macron et puis reprocher à quelqu'un
effectivement tout sera probablement
dans la façon dont on le fera dans la
façon dont les explications seront
données mais aller auprès des gens
utiliser les leviers qui sont importants
et qui effectivement donne accès à des
gens qui se sent ça n'ont peut-être pas
pourrait dire des habitudes
d'information de lecture approfondie des
discours des politiques ça peut-être
peut-être une bonne façon de renouer ce
lien qui est clairement cassé depuis
puis les gilet jaune entre les gens la
population et puis les décideurs donc
pourquoi pas sur tout
au pire c'est inutile disons voilà mon
pire si ces bases et vous allez briser
cette belle unanimité sur le plateau à
moitié comment peut il parler aux jeunes
s'intéressent très grave c'est qu'on ne
soit pas là en fait toujours trop elle
en fait des tonnes et déjà ne pas
obliger dire qu'elle est co animatrice
on aurait dit marché n'ya pas va
participer à une émission organisée par
n'avons personne n'aurait parlé puis
d'un rôle en fait trop si c'est que elle
était au premier rang de ceux qui
attaquent et hanouna à l'époque parce
que lloris les premières régies par les
juges mais à l'époque l'événement
saisissez le csa parce que les ide les
yeux jaunes par l'est et hanouna et
dénoncer l'homophobie d'hanouna et 90
ans et les nouilles qu'on mettait dans
le style de jeu c'est pas qui ce pauvre
gars qui en est fait croire qu'il avait
tué quelqu'un vraiment tout ça n'est pas
grande importance mois du point de vue
en tout cas de la pédagogie gwendal je
pense qu'il faut parler à tout le monde
du point de vue de la télévision je
pense que comment est ce que je crois
c'est qu'on peut s'adresser en matière
d'information plus grand nombre sans
rabaisser le niveau de ce qu'on dit et
je pense que le gouvernement gagnerait à
soutenir des émissions du service public
qu'ils soient pas forcément prétentieuse
ni ennuyeuse en disant on va parler au
plus grand nombre à travers de la
pédagogie intelligente contreras nous
n'a pas mais le fait par ailleurs ça la
veille elle sera dans l'émission de
france
surtout il ya des publics différents et
ceux qui sont devant les émission
politique de france 2 c'est pas du tout
du tout le même public que ceux qui sont
devant devant chez elle c'est voit la
justification qu'elle donne et je pense
qu'en termes sociologiques la raison
c'est à dire que s'ils cherchent à la
mission qu'on peut toucher un public
vraiment populaire qui sont de meilleur
aloi enfin je crois que sur dans la
province veut parler à tout le monde on
doit parler à tout le monde peut-être
pas que n'importe qui on et ça donne
l'occasion de faire un petit tour de
table sur
les débats animés par emmanuel macron
les deux précédents celui annoncé jeudi
avec les maires à vous avez vous un
débat et une séance de
questions-réponses et ironie alors
allez-y quart de point de vue rhétorique
moi je trouve ça très bien ce qu'ils
ferment et des bas non les bas c'est ce
que nous faisons là là ces questions
réponses c'est à dire c'est une méga
interview avec super explications de la
politique du président on n'appelle pas
ça
stricto sensu dans le dictionnaire un
débat dans un débat vous avez par
définition notamment un droit de reprise
droit de retour un droit de répondre au
président ali keita vous pouvez c'est un
peu comme si on appelait un cours
magistral un débat en réalité parce que
c'est l'ex asi apparence assis à part en
guerre il comme une partie
interpellation assez vigoureuse
parfois la question mais on court aussi
parfois de temps en temps il égalise non
moi j'ai toujours un peu perplexe sur ce
débat jean la vraie question
effectivement c'est soit les gens auront
mis ont donné ce qu'ils ont sur le coeur
et ça les soulagera pas ce qu'ils ont
écrit sur les lecteurs fontaine dans la
mairie où ils seront allés parler ils
ont pris la parole et ils sont contents
première possibilité deuxième scénario
mon avis qui est malheureusement plus
probable c'est il ne se retrouve
absolument pas une route rue ne se
retrouveront pas dans la synthèse
forcément extrêmement synthétise ben oui
la synthèse très courte qui aura fait
des choix qui aurait enlevé beaucoup de
choses et qui sera forcément plaire
énormément de frustration est donc en
réalité une déception encore plus grande
qui fait que la la colère pourrait être
ravivée potentiellement par le résultat
c'est ce que je crains et je sais pas ce
que j'espère est le site aragon il le
sent lui-même mais pour le moment si on
en croit les récents sondages mais
plutôt à higuain pour emmanuel macron
way et résiste bien je pense que c'est
un exercice où il est bon
où il n'a pas peur d'y aller non plus
lui au charbon que c'est finalement dans
la situation actuelle je pense que ça
s'imposait il fallait qu'ils renouent
absolument avec ces corps intermédiaires
et cela je pense que c'est une bonne
chose
est-ce que profondément ces mêmes ils
sont dopés qui rend leurs certitudes ou
qui du coup ils sont motivés pour faire
ce débat est qu est ce que ça va faire
avancer le débat différemment est ce que
il va pas découler de tout ça une grande
frustration je pense que bien sûr que si
mais la question au point où on en est
aujourd'hui c'est que les conséquences
de ce débat on les connaît pas encore
mais ne pas y aller aurait été une faute
incroyable donc voilà une main il faut y
aller il faut il faut assumer à tous les
niveaux y compris sur les plateaux vous
l'avez dit souvent sur ce plateau
d'ailleurs c'était aussi une façon pour
l'événement gagner du temps de se donner
un peu d'air
il ya deux qui souhaitent avoir question
de la partition de ma partition
manqueront oui il est bon ou il fallait
fermer en forêt p il peut pas
monopoliser le débat et surtout à
chatila réseau de côté car le côté
performances à chaque fois ces
investissements vont s'habituer
les gens n'en sait et si côté lundi
qu'il enfile justement il la 4è 5è tue
personne regarde c'est pas possible
c'est pas bien que le prénom est celle
de la banaliser ce point là donc je
pense que le mieux est l'ennemi du bien
il faut pas se laisser les adorent sa
préface est nommé diamant faut s'arrêter
maintenant on a compris il faut que
donné de le tendre le micro si j'ose
dire le relais à d'autres des ministres
le premier ministre
et puis qu'il ya un débat qui suit
l'idée c'est de faire nous un débat
entre les français et leur est donnée au
président et les élections edouard
philippe faso au maire ça donne pas tout
à fait les pas les mères à ce moment là
maintenant le vrai débat c'est un débat
entre le président et des mères ce débat
entre les français donc il faut
maintenant faire parler français et que
là dessus et des animateurs et plein de
gens qui parlent mais mais mais là on a
trop le faire c'est l'impression d'un
espèce de monopole d'une porte parole
d'en haut ce qu'il va en bas et c'est le
contraire de l'effet souhaité ça c'est
le premier sujet le deuxième sujet
absolument entier d'un jour j est ce
qu'on disait les uns les autres
c'est la question de la sortie de ce
débat qu'est ce qu'on fera quand une
fois que les joueurs ont demandés on
veut le référendum d'initiative
citoyenne
on veut le doublement du smic on veut
l'arrêt des agressions des retraites on
veut évidemment lié ce n est là qu est
ce qu il a la réponse ça va être
compliqué parce que c'est évidemment ça
qui va sortir
ils vont pas demander la réforme des
retraites voulue par macro ou la réforme
de l'assurance chômage c'est faut pas
compter dessus
donc la sortie du débat fait hyper
compliqué ça permet en attendant de
calmer le jeu de 8 ans il fallait le
faire mais mais ça veut dire que ça
difficile a le regret que je vous laisse
confirmé que en cours magistral et des
interpellations d'étudiants qui sont
aussi vigoureux alors des relations je
vous invite interpellation vigoureuse ou
pas vous le faites en tout cas pour le
grand débat que lance le figaro magazine
vous le savez vous pouvez participer par
mail le grand débat sur les thèmes
lancés par le gouvernement mais aussi
avec quelques ajouts le figaro magazine
qui lance aussi le débat sur la famille
sur la bioéthique sur les impôts
vous participez encore une fois vous
êtes les bienvenus merci beaucoup à tous
les quatre et pour terminer je vous
propose quelques notes d'accordéon celui
de marcel azzola dont on a appris la
mort aujourd'hui il avait joué avec piaf
il avait joué pour jacques tati mais
aussi pour jeanne brel qu'on écoute
vesoul chauffe marcel
[Musique]